how'd you guys get into chess
when when did you first let's say when
did you first fall in love with chess
so we both started playing when we were
pretty young around six years old that's
when our dad taught us and
i enjoyed playing chess because i had
good results early on but a lot of it
was being pushed from my dad to play
chess and i only really started loving
it when we moved from canada and we
started moving a lot and chess was the
one stable thing that i had and it was
also where all my
friends were so it was kind of that
foundational thing for me
and that's when i started studying chess
very intensely and when i started
putting in the hours out of my own will
not because i was being pushed by my dad
that's when i started really loving it
and i even wanted to take time off
college to just focus on chess
so training and competing training and
competing yeah it was when i was doing
it for myself that i started getting my
best results
and actually enjoying the thing and
really enjoying it yeah i would spend
summer vacation studying for tournaments
and my mom would come and say you need
to make friends go leave the house and
i'd be like no i need to play chess and
i i remember those moments that you
rebelled by playing chess yeah exactly
how did you get into it yeah my my
experience with
loving in high school is very opposite
from alex's but right my sister was
playing and my dad taught me when andrea
was cool in high school unlike me you
are uh i i wouldn't say cool i'd save
more balance and i was interested in
other hobbies in my childhood if i ever
really did love chess there's certainly
moments about like traveling and being
together with my family and spending
those moments together but those are
more the social and the experiences but
funny enough like i think my happiest
moment where i really played the game
for my own enjoyment was probably my
most recent tournament
because
this was after obviously we've been
streaming and i'm no longer in high
school but when i was in school i was
always playing for college and for the
results trying to build a resume so i
was too stressed out about the pressure
to really enjoy the game whereas when i
just played my first tournament so it
was like
after like a two-year break because of
the pandemic
and it was also all live on twitch so
there was some pressure but it was the
first time that like i was really eager
to study for the game sitting and
focusing since we've been streaming and
not getting distracted by something else
in years like i said and the tournament
experience i hit my highest rating and
it was my best tournament ever and i
think most of that is because it came
from my own enjoyment
so
you didn't enjoy the domination because
i think you like did really well right
this is like a couple months ago uh oh
yeah yeah the tournament well of course
i think the results came from enjoying
the tournament because i would be in
high school like studying double triple
the amount of time like six hours every
day compared to this tournament i didn't
even prepare for it and for three years
i wouldn't be able to pass one rating
whereas in this one term and i passed it
by like 70 points without even any
preparation so it was i think as soon as
you stop worrying about the competitions
when the games get much better what does
it mean to pass a rating so i was stuck
at 1900. 1900 is 100 points off of
expert yeah
usually when you reach 2000 you're
considered an expert which is the rating
andre i was going for okay expert that's
a good technical term or this like
it's more of a colloquial term where if
somebody's around a 2000 you're playing
them in a tournament they won't have the
actual title next to their name but you
say i'm playing an expert what about
like the the more official things like
master yeah that have to do with the
ratings yeah so national master in the
us is when you're 2200
okay and what's international master
international master is based off of a
different system the fide system which
is international to be an international
master it's
2400 and you have to have three
international master norms
yeah i think magnus said he's uh 28 6
something that was yeah and then he said
uh that's pretty decent now well he
always
tells us the thing is i think what he
meant
is
that's a decent rating because it
accurately captures his actual level
so it's uh it's not over inflated or
underinflated and so on
and so the discussion there was how do
you get
can a human being get to 2 900.
and then he says because my current
rating is pretty decent at representing
my skill level it's going to be a long
road to actually get there right because
it's like
so you have to beat people your same
level that's how the number increases
exactly
yeah and you beat a bunch of people in
the tournament right that that are
higher than that i'm very lucky i was
playing i was really nervous because my
category was like 200 points above my
rating and of course
i was very rusty and i didn't plan a
tournament in a while but it went pretty
well
you